Do you have something for sleep? If a hard time is going to sleep and stay to sleep,
this is a loaded question because there are so many possible causes of inability to fall asleep
and stay asleep. Really have a hard time falling asleep is a totally different problem
than someone who wakes up and then can't go to sleep. So if you are somebody who is waking up,
and then you're and can't fall asleep, that is let's just walk through some possibilities here
because there's a lot of different possibilities when we talk about sleep issues.
So number one is I can't fall asleep. I go to bed, that's what's called insomnia,
but it's time to go to bed. It's really my time to go to bed. I got to get up at six o'clock
at it's 10.30 and go to bed and you lay at bed for an hour or so before you can fall asleep.
That's insomnia. So insomnia can be caused from multiple things there. We've spoken about it in
past Zoom calls, stop looking at screen time several hours before bed because watching a screen
like a computer screen or your phone screen or a television screen, the screens are functioning
at a very high hertz. 60, 50 to 60 hertz is what they're functioning at. That is in training your
brain at 50 to 60 hertz. Your brain waves are only supposed to be functioning at the highest hertz
of about 28 hertz, which is a high beta wave. So you're training your brain at a super high beta wave.
Of course your brain can't go that high but you're in training your brain to be a high beta wave.
Nobody can fall asleep in a high beta wave. You have to get down to a theta wave to get to sleep
somewhere between five and 15 hertz to be able to start to fall asleep. So it's difficult
to be sluky at your phone and it's time to go to bed. So you put your phone by your side of your
bed and you try to go to sleep. That itself doesn't allow your brain to get to a theta wave to get
to sleep. That itself can be a problem. So number one, you can't fall asleep. Stop using screens
several hours before you go to bed. Well, I do that already and I still can't fall asleep.
Okay. Yeah, the thing that could be taking places is your is your there have a little teeny
gland in your brain called your pedial gland that's supposed to be secreting melatonin at the time
before you're supposed to go to sleep. So you can use some melatonin. It's typically recommended
that you use about three milligrams of melatonin about a half hour before bed to help fall asleep.
We have melatonin in our store. We also have a product called insomnetol in our store that has
some melatonin, has some valerian root and some other herbs that could be very calming to help you fall
asleep. So number one, screen time, number two, low melatonin levels. Melatonin levels are
also controlled and go along with an adverse relationship with cortisol. Cortisol is a stress
hormone. So if I have under a lot of stress, this is why if you have ever been under a lot of stress,
it's difficult for you to fall asleep. So it is because if you have a lot of stress, you have a lot
of cortisol secreted. If you have a lot of cortisol flying through your bloodstream, you won't
make melatonin or you won't release melatonin from the pedial gland and it's going to be difficult
to fall asleep. So dealing with stress levels, that's why sometimes people do better exercise eat
at night before bed because it could help burn off some of that cortisol and that helps them
their body release melatonin to help them fall asleep. So exercising before bed can be beneficial
in that case. There's other reasons why you can't fall asleep and we could talk for a long time
on just the sleep patterns. Now waking up in the middle of the night and not being able to fall
back asleep has to do with other issues that could be very complex too but usually are not related
to melatonin. They can be related to a adrenal burnout because at night, so at night, you're at a
fasting state. So you have it eaten since night of clock or something like that and now you're fasting
but there's one part of your body that needs glucose all night long. Your muscles don't need a lot
of glucose because you're not exercising. The rest of your body doesn't need a lot of glucose
so you're not doing a whole lot of activity. Things aren't in a stall mode while you're sleeping
but your brain is always active. In order for your brain to continue to be active, it needs glucose.
Your adrenals release cortisol at night to stimulate glucose breakdown of glycogen stores in the liver
to keep a steady glucose level to keep your brain alive. So what a person says, I wake up about water
to I fall asleep just fine. I wake up about water to a clock and I can't fall back asleep again.
That's usually because their adrenals are deficient. Probably because of past stress, maybe current
stress but their adrenals are deficient. So they need some adaptogens or some adrenal support
and if you can support the adrenal to get back healthy adrenals again, then all that whole system
can start working again. There could be some other things with some mineral deficiency that can cause
a person to not be able to fall asleep or not be able to get back asleep at night either.
And as this little diagram talks about leg cramps, that would be the mineral deficiency issues.
Acid reflux, well that's good back to gut health and other issues like pain. So pain can
be an issue that keeps a person up and doesn't allow them to get back asleep.
I would suggest if you really have issues with insomnia and sleep patterns that you do call
and make an appointment to talk about them if you can't deal with it to kid figure it out with some
of the brief things I spoke about here. Another thing to try is the insomnia programs on your
life. We've had people say they've tried them but it didn't help at all. We've had other people say
they tried them and it was a miracle thing for them. So melatonin, think about that.
Side note on that, high dose melatonin has been shown in several studies that it's been helpful
for some cancer patients to help with their cancer. So melatonin is not contraindicated for cancer
patients. It can be helpful for cancer patients. So I would not discourage you from trying melatonin
to think, you know, I don't want to do that. Then I'm going to be depended upon it. It can be
good for your kids or so. I would say definitely try melatonin. In insomnia solved product we have.
We've had a lot of people with very good success with that.